need to pass this permission
yes um past i have a i have a question
so um
last week you on your topic um obedience
has side effects
yes and again this morning
you spoke about the sabbath
and so um
i have friends and from time to time we
have you know discussions about the
seventh day the seventh day yes yes and
so i have i have one friend and he says
well
the bible doesn't the bible didn't say
monday tuesday when sunday monday
tuesday wednesday thursday friday
matter of fact it says first second
third fourth sixth the only day that it
named
was the sabbath
so his argument is um
wednesday could be the first day so my
seventh day could be
the following wednesday mm-hmm what why
can i
you know worship on that day make that
day holy all right so my question is
since um
you know god named first second third
fourth fifth man made today sunday
morning tuesday wednesday thursday how
do you all right okay
advocates have a bible study method
called here a little
very little
light upon line preset upon prison all
right
let me ask you this
on what day
was jesus did jesus rise from the tomb
the bible says on the first day all
consistently the first day matthew mark
luke's first day now
let's forget adventists for a while
on which day do christians celebrate
easter
all christians celebrate easter on
sunday because they know from the bible
what happened on that day that's when
you see easter celebrates the
resurrection of jesus so your friend who
has a problem let him look at easter now
on what day was christ crucified they
also celebrated it's called what good
friday
and there's no argument the whole
christian world celebrates you look at
your calendars and you'll see easter is
on a sunday
now you tell me what's the day between
friday and saturday there's seven
[Music]
simple if you're honest
and you're thinking the bible does not
leave us with doubt on critical issues
we have to think
that the catholics celebrate east on
sunday and the same people who change
the law huh they celebrate easter on
sunday
they celebrate good friday on friday ash
wednesday on wednesday and holy thursday
on thursday are you following me and
there's also an entire nation that has
been on the earth for thousands of years
who know when the seventh day is the
jewish nation
all right